CHANDA: On August 7th last year
Mrs. Benazir Bhutto
came to Yale University and sat down with me
at this studio
to discuss the state of affairs in her country.
She told me why she wanted to go back home.
She said
it was not for herself
but to save,
as she put it,
"Save my country from
destruction and
disintegration."
On December 27th last year
she was assassinated just after she had delivered
a speech
condemning extremism.
In the interview she gave to me
on August 7th last year,
she said
"We want an end to the attacks on NATO and Afghan forces
in nearby Afghanistan by the militants
and we want an end to the
militants
who try to hijack our foreign policy by conducting
attacks on the Indian parliament
and on other sites in India.
So our world-vision
collides rather dramatically with the world-vision
of the extremists."
How true she was.
We are pleased to have in our studios
Mrs. Benazir Bhutto,
two-time prime minister of Pakistan,
and we are extremely pleased to have her
with us today
at a time
when Pakistan is facing
a critical
choice
about its future.
Welcome, Mrs. Bhutto.
BHUTTO: Thank you, Mr. Nanda [Chanda]. It's lovely to be at Yale.
CHANDA: Thank you. Politics is as far removed
from poetry as possible
so I cannot resist
reading a little poem that you wrote
some years ago.
"One has might,
The other, right.
One has the sword,
The other, the pen.
Guns rust and fall apart,
Ideas live forever."
So do you think President Musharraf's guns are rusting
and that is why he's turning to you to do a deal?
BHUTTO: Certainly, there has been a degree of unease
within Pakistan. General Musharraf
had given a charter of where he wanted to take the country
which was towards a true democracy and a
moderate society.
However, in the last six years,
we've seen that the extremists have spread
throughout the country, and we used to think
it was just
in the tribal areas, but indeed the Red Mosque
Incident in our capital city of Islamabad
showed that the tentacles of extremism
were spreading
and that poses grave challenges to
Pakistan from within,
as well as complicates the external picture.
CHANDA: So the reason why he is
now willing to
sit down with you
is because he's
feeling that he's no longer in
full control?
BHUTTO: I see it differently. I think after 9/11,
when the first general elections were held
under General Musharraf,
it was less than a year later,
and he was seen very much as a strong ally
of the West on which the international
community could depend
to reform the madrasahs
and to constrain and restrain the terrorist
elements within the country.
But unfortunately, since then,
there has been the rise of suicide bombings.
Innocent people in Pakistan, like our women and children,
are being killed,
and I think now the international community
has started supporting the democratic process.
Within Pakistan we've had a pro-democracy
movement
which has gathered strength as poverty in
the country increased and people's needs were neglected.
So this confluence has made the
elections of 2007 very important.
All the independent polls show that the
Pakistan People's Party and I
would go on to win any fair
election.
So I think that this is what is the need
of drawing people together.
In Pakistan we have different fault lines:
we have one on dictatorship versus
democracy,
and we have a second one
on moderation versus fundamentalism
or extremism.
So I think that General Musharraf is trying to
seek a way
out by having these contacts with the Pakistan
People's Party.
CHANDA: Nawaz Sharif has suggested that
one should do everything
to remove the military from politics,
and what
you may be
trying to do
would be seen by people as prolonging the
military rule rather than
getting rid of the military altogether.
BHUTTO: I know that is what Mr. Nawaz Sharif is saying,
but I don't agree,
and I find it very strange that Mr. Nawaz Sharif
talked to General Musharraf and got out
in the year 2000,
which did prolong
military rule in my country.
I was also offered that if I quit politics
for ten years, all the charges against me would
be dropped
and my husband would be released, but I refused
that offer
because I felt that it would prolong
military rule in my country,
and now I'm talking because this is about
getting the
uniform
out of the office of the presidency.
This is about facilitating the transfer
to democracy,
and as I said, we're talking, but we're not
there yet.
So
I'm really not in a position to tell
you today
that there really will be
an agreement on the facilitated transfer
to democracy,
but I do know one thing:
that a facilitated transfer to democracy is far
more preferable
than a situation of chaos on the streets
that can be taken advantage of
by extremist elements.
So as a Pakistani leader who wants to
see the stability and the unity of my country
and see Pakistan go on the path of moderation,
I think it's important for me to explore
peaceful political options
of a transfer to democracy.
I will point out to you that no one believed
when the Shah of Iran was facing street riots
that it would end up
in an ayatollah revolution, but that's what
happened.
And when the Mensheviks took to the streets in Russia,
no one expected the Bolsheviks.
So, you know, when we have a situation where
we have militants who are armed,
and we have political parties who are unarmed,
I would do my best
to have a peaceful transfer,
but if that fails, maybe I won't be able to
stop
the street agitation
and that would be dangerous, so let's hope
that we can indeed get, either through the
negotiations we are having
or through the Supreme Court of Pakistan,
some kind of a
facilitated and
peaceful
revival of the constitution,
restoration of the democratic process,
and a redress of people's social and economic
needs
so that terrorism and militancy
can be undermined.
CHANDA: According to some press reports, the agreement
that has been reached between you and President Musharraf
is that
he will be a civilian president while you'll be--
a civilian president who'll be in charge of national
security and foreign affairs,
and you will be
chief executive,
and
the ban on you
as running for prime minister for the third time
would be lifted and your family can return.
Is there
any truth in this?
BHUTTO: These are certainly some of the issues that
are being discussed.
General Musharraf
wants to get elected from the present assemblies.
He thinks that's legal.
We in the PPP believe that it's not legal,
so this matter is going to be decided really
by the courts
and perhaps by
public pressure too,
but ultimately it's a decision of
legal dispute.
The elections are going to be held later this
year. My concern is that those elections
should be fair, free, and impartial.
I believe what the
international crisis
group
that military intervention in the country
is creating failed state
which poses a danger to Pakistan's own security
as well as regional
security. So I'd like those elections to be fair,
and I think any attempt by General Musharraf
to manipulate those elections
will lead to a far bigger internal crisis
with far-reaching
repercussions.
We haven't reached an agreement yet because
everything the regime says it will do
is post-presidential, -prime ministerial, and
-parliamentary elections
and my party doesn't want to be lead up the garden path.
So we believe that the cooperation needs
to be calibrated
so that there are different phases
of implementation--
CHANDA: So, is it possible that
if he
gets re-elected by the parliament one more time,
but he
makes you the interim Prime Minister so
that
there can be free and fair election
in December,
would you accept that?
BHUTTO: No, no no no. I'm not looking at this for myself.
I'm looking at this for the empowerment
of my people,
and I'm looking at this for saving my country
from a militant takeover or, God forbid,
disintegration. I think it's the worst crisis
that we've faced
since 1971.
What we are looking for
is
a cooperation once the uniform is off.
The PPP cannot cooperate with a uniform presidency
which blurs the distinction
between civil and
military rule.
Because the PPP has been fighting every single
military dictatorship that there has been
in the country
and we symbolize the aspirations of the people
for a democratic Pakistan.
The PPP is also looking for the holding of
fair elections.
We wouldn't like a situation where the elections
are manipulated
and then we are offered a handful of ministries
in return for legitimizing a fraudulent election.
CHANDA: So what would be necessary for you to consider
the election to be fair and free? What would be
the conditions?
BHUTTO: Very good question, very good question.
The all-parties conference held in July
earlier this year
which was hosted, which was called for, by the
Alliance for the Restoration of Democracy,
came up with the points that need to be implemented
by the Election Commission of Pakistan
for the holding of fair elections,
and earlier,
the very widely-respected international
group
known as the NDI, the National Democratic Institute,
held a round table of all political parties
in Pakistan,
and the round table also came up with proposals,
and we have handed these proposals
over
to General Musharraf's side, and they have been promising
us for some months
that they will actually implement various proposals
that have come during the time
for fair elections, and they keep reassuring
us that the elections will be fair
but unfortunately, except for transparent
ballot boxes,
none of those reforms have been implemented
which is really leading to some unease in the
PPP
circles, and indeed the opposition circles,
that now the elections are around the corner.
When is this all going to happen? When are
these reforms going to be
lifted?
Then there is also the issue of a balance
between the presidency and the parliament.
I see little point in getting a parliament elected
where the prime minister is thrown out two
months later.
I mean, we had this in the 90's
where the presidential power to dismiss parliaments
was used ruthlessly, not only against Mr. Nawaz Sharif
and myself twice,
but even against Mr. Junejo.
So we feel that there is little point in taking
our country backwards to the instability of
the 90's.
We have to move forward towards a better political
system where we know what the role and responsibility
of the parliament is,
and what the role and responsibility
of the president is.
CHANDA: How does one reach that without a constitutional reform?
BHUTTO: Well, General Musharraf assures us that he wants
parliament to have all the powers,
and he says he doesn't want any powers himself,
but there's a dichotomy because the constitution
actually gives all the key powers
to the presidency. So this is an issue on which
the discussions are still ongoing,
because while General Musharraf says he wants all
powers to be with the parliament,
he seems unwilling to give up the presidential
power to dismiss
the parliament. So we are still having ongoing
discussions on that particular issue,
but we agree, both sides agree, that the
reform should be implemented for fair elections;
both sides agree that the ban on the twice-elected
prime minister should go;
both sides agree that the moderate forces should
come together;
both sides agree there should be a level playing field
and an end to moderated litigation.
So there's a lot of agreement, apparent
agreement, on a lot of issues, while one
or two still
are outstanding,
but right now the issue is: when is the implementation
going to take place,
and then which phase is this implementation going
to take place? To complicate the issue,
the ruling party has been saying
that nothing will change and that they're
not really negotiating with the PPP
they're just they're giving, in our local language:
"dheel"
That means a long rope.
So this, and they keep talking about how they're
going to impose emergency.
So some people have cynically remarked
that the Red Mosque Incident
in Islamabad was actually cooked up
by elements of the cabinet to provide
a pretext for emergency,
but the plan failed
when the presidency decided
to take action
against the militants. So you know, we're talking
here about a country
from which many key Al-Qaeda
suspects have been,
or terrorists, have been arrested,
like Abu Zubaydah, and Khalid Sheikh from Pindi,
and Ramzi Binalshibh
from Karachi.
So we must remember that this is not just
a war for Pakistan's heart and soul;
this is something that will have far-reaching
ramifications
on militant struggles across our borders.
We in the PPP are very determined
to build peace.
In fact, we say the message of Islam
is peace,
and we want peace for our citizens inside our
country;
we want an end to the attacks on NATO and
Afghan troops in nearby Afghanistan,
and we want an end to the militants who try to
hijack our foreign policy
by conducting attacks on the Indian parliament
or on other sites
in India.
So our world vision
collides rather dramatically
with the word vision of the extremists. Now
Musharraf has said he's for moderation,
and so we hope that he can do something
up front
that can facilitate moderate forces coming together.
CHANDA: President Chaudhry Shujaat Hussain
of the Pakistan Muslim League has said that
maybe
there will be an imposition of emergency
and the assembly will be extended for one year.
If that happens,
then what will be the position of
your party?
BHUTTO: I believe my party would join with all
the other political parties
to protest any attempt to defer
the elections.
What we have been telling
all of the other political parties-- we had
it all-parties conference in
London
and we all agreed on certain points
for the holding of fair, free, and impartial elections,
but whereas the other political parties wanted
to start a movement straightaway,
we said, "No,
we have to wait.
We have to wait and see whether either the elections
are postponed,
or we have to wait and see whether the elections
are rigged
but to start an agitation at this point
might tempt the rulers into
imposing emergency."
But I do think that if the doors of
election
are shut on us
and emergency is imposed
or the elections are rigged, then certainly
the PPP, with the other political parties,
civil groups, and NGOs
in Pakistan, would put pressure like in the Ukraine
during the Orange Revolution
for the empowerment of our people.
CHANDA: So you can see a street protest of the type that
so recently involving the chief justice
perhaps a bigger
departisanization of political parties?
BHUTTO: That's right, I very much can see that
happening. I wouldn't like to see it happening because
I don't think that Pakistan needs anarchy
or civil strife or bloodshed,
but both sides have a responsibility
to prevent that,
and the elections now
give General Musharraf and the presidency, as well as the military establishment,
an opportunity to take Pakistan safety
from one phase
of governance to another phase of governance.
The spoilers are there. After all, why would those
who have politically benefited from
firing the shots from the shoulders of the
military
want to have fair elections which would
see them give up power
and go into opposition? So I understand that
there will be elements like the ruling PMLQ
which will do everything to scuttle a process
of reconciliation
and resolution, moving Pakistan onto a moderate course,
but I think it's important for General Musharraf
and the military establishment
to stay the course,
not to defer the elections, not to impose
emergency,
and to make sure that those elections are credible
and satisfy the public. The public are
the important people.
We need international observers;
otherwise there is just going to be name-calling, so
we need a third party
that can certify whether the elections are going to
be fair or not.
CHANDA: President Musharraf has been criticized
recently,
severely, in the United States,
for not doing enough
to actually
capture the
Al-Qaeda suspects
hiding in Pakistan.
What do you think of that? Do you think he is
doing enough?
BHUTTO: Well, I know that, as a Pakistani, it certainly
hurts me very much
when I see that inevitably the trail of terrorists
leads back to my country.
If it's an issue of the Tube bomber,
we find that he had visited Pakistan, or
if it's an issue of John [Richard] Reed the shoe bomber, we
find that he had made a telephone call to Pakistan,
if it's capturing the CEO
of al-Qaeda, Khalid Sheikh, we find that he was
captured
in Pakistan's garrison city
of Rawalpindi so it bothers us Pakistanis that
our great nation
should be associated with such elements. We
don't want to make our country
hospitable to such elements, and my party
severely criticized
the peace agreement that was signed in 2006
with the Taliban elements in the tribal
regions of Pakistan,
and we feel that our tribal areas
were ceded to foreign elements: to Afghan Taliban
and Arab and Chechen militant fighters,
and now those groups actually administer
parts of our territory
and hold our people hostage. They dispense
their own form of justice; they teach little
twelve-year old boys to behead
those they accuse of being spies. I mean, little children
should have pens in their hands.
Little children should have schools to go to.
Little children should have dreams.
CHANDA: So why is it that
it can still continue in still Pakistani territory?
BHUTTO: Well, this is is a question that General Musharraf
and his regime must answer.
While they have certainly verbally expressed their
sentiment for the right course of eliminating terrorism
and extremism in the country, unfortunately
they have not been able assert the rule of law
in the country.
My government would move swiftly
to assert law and order
in the tribal areas of Pakistan,
to hunt down the al-Qaeda leaders who are
trying to take advantage of
the lack of law and order there,
to stop the drug trade, which is actually funding
and fueling terrorism,
and to reform the political madrasahs, who use the
name "madrasah",
but are actually militant headquarters
using women and children as human shields.
I'm a woman; I'm a mother;
I don't want to see the innocent women and
children of my country
held up as human shields and killed
as they were during the Red Mosque Incident,
and I think it's the duty of government
to provide the protection of the life and liberty
of its citizens.
CHANDA: So, given that fact that,
despite
President Musharraf's verbal assurances that
he's doing everything,
it is still continuing--in fact, increasing--
can you blame the Americans for saying they will
have to intervene without Pakistani permission?
BHUTTO: Well I can understand why they say that
because they feel that Islamabad has
failed
to stop the terrorists and that's why they
would like to move in,
but I would really urge against that.
I believe that the violation of
Pakistan's sovereignty
through unauthorized military action
will have very adverse consequences.
When under attack, all Pakistanis will
forget their differences and they will all
unite, so any unauthorized action
would pit the NATO against all of the people
of Pakistan, and I don't think that's advisable.
But I think what is advisable
is to have a close working relationship, and
certainly when the PPP is elected to power,
we intend to restore law and order
to our tribal areas
and prevent the militants from attacking NATO,
so we intend to take away the causes
that can today threaten air strikes
against Pakistan, and we also intend to work
very closely
with NATO
and with the United States and other
countries
to eliminate terrorism, to help us also
in our tribal areas,
to eliminate, through intelligence-sharing and
other means of cooperation.
CHANDA: Pakistan has always sought a
strategic depth in Afghanistan as a part
of its security policy.
Do you think that
policy has
led to
this alliance, de facto alliance, between Pakistani
ISI and Taliban?
Can you change that?
BHUTTO: Well I certainly hope I can change it.
I believe that the policy of strategic depth
has backfired,
and in fact it was in 1998
that I stood up in the parliament of Pakistan
and I said
that the policy of strategic depth is turning
into one of strategic threat
for Pakistan,
and the passage of years have shown to me
that indeed such a policy is leading to militancy,
suicide bombers,
weaponization, drug trade in Pakistan,
to an increase in poverty and unemployment
as the priorities of the state
shift and these issues are neglected.
So I want an end to that policy of strategic
depth. I think Afghanistan
has traditionally been viewed either as a buffer state
or as a forward-policy state where there is
strategic depth,
and throughout history, different
empires, even the British empire
or the Greeks when they even came to that
area, have looked at the issue in terms
of strategic depth or buffer state,
and I think for us it's much better to
have an Afghanistan
that is peaceful,
that allows us to trade with it, that has
good relations
with all its neighbors, and I think it's very
promising that Afghanistan has joined
the South Asian Association of Regional Countries,
and I think for India, Pakistan, Afghanistan,
and the other countries of SAARC,
this is where we should concentrate. We should try to create
the economic interdependencies
that allowed Europe to emerge from the
ravages of two world wars
and build a common market that has given
unprecedented growth and an increase in the
standard of living of ordinary Europeans.
I mean, in the 50's people were all on rations,
and now they're spoiled for choice.
CHANDA: Another issue where, I think,
you mentioned India--Kashmir--
seems to have been defused a little bit.
Do you see any
prospect that,
if you return to Pakistan as
Prime Minister,
you will have a different approach than what has
been tried by Musharraf?
BHUTTO: No, I think Musharraf did the right thing
in following the spirit of the Simla Agreement
which my father had signed with
Prime Minister Indira Gandhi,
and that the spirit of the declaration,
the Islamabad declaration, wherein Rajiv Gandhi
and I had decided to work for peaceful relations.
Certainly, the fighting over Kargil
and the one million men who faced each
other eyeball-to-eyeball
after the Indian parliament attack drove
home
the dramatic consequences of a conflict
between India and Pakistan, who are both nuclear-capable
states.
I don't think we can afford this; I think Musharraf
did the right thing.
We've been very critical of him when he's done
the wrong thing,
but vis-à-vis the policy with India, or vis-à-vis,
the policy with women's rights,
vis-à-vis restoring women's seats in parliament,
well, we supported those measures because
we don't believe
in being totally rejectionist or being totally
accepting.
We believe in dealing with issue by issue.
So yes,
we would continue
the process of dialogue with India.
And not only that: I hope that in the 60th year
of our anniversary
(both countries are turning 60 in a few
day's time),
I hope that we can come and build a peace
treaty
that will enable our people to turn their
backs
on an unhappy past and look to a brighter future.
Kashmir is an issue between us, it is
a dispute,
but then you know, India has a dispute with
China
over the border, but they don't go to war
with each other.
So we need to learn that we can have
differing opinions
without actually allowing them
to transform themselves into conflict,
bloodshed, terrorism, militancy, or war.
CHANDA: When you were Prime Minister,
how much were you aware of
A.Q. Khan's
nuclear arms sales activities?
BHUTTO: I was not at all aware of his
nuclear arms sale
opportunities.
In fact, as Prime Minister of Pakistan, my government
gave birth to the Benazir Nuclear Doctrine.
Under this nuclear doctrine,
Pakistan would not export nuclear technology--that
was a cardinal principle of the doctrine--
and we would not put together the
components of a
weapon unless our security was threatened,
and then we would not shape and mold
uranium into nuclear
parts.
So it was a policy that was bipartisan;
it came through with consultation with the
presidency and the armed forces,
so it was accepted by all as part of
the national interest,
and, to my knowledge, it held
until India detonated its nuclear devices,
and then Prime Minister Nawaz Sharif in retaliation
detonated
in Pakistan.
So it was quite a shock that I learned
that the no-export in nuclear technology had been
violated,
and then I would not have believed it until
A.Q. Khan came on television
and confessed,
and now the only question before us is,
"Did he fall on his sword
to protect others,
or were there others also involved?"
For that, my party called for a
parliamentary inquiry,
because Pakistan can't afford to
endanger its own nuclear system
by scientists who begin to smuggle
and proliferate
weapons of mass destruction.
CHANDA: But he was flying C1-30 of Pakistan Air Force
to carry stuff,
so is it possible that he was doing it alone?
Well, this is the issue that we want resolved at the inquiry
because it's amazing to
think that he could have access
to C1-30 aircraft and go to
North Korea, and not only go to North Korea
but go to so many
other countries. I remember in
General Musharraf's regime
there had been a full-page advertisement taken out
by the Ministry of Commerce
advertising the sale of nuclear components,
and many of us were shocked.
This was before A.Q. Khan's whole issue had been
unearthed.
So it was actually very shocking and particularly
in this world in which we live,
you know, where terrorists want to get their hands
on weapons of mass destruction.
The entire world community, including Pakistanis
who live in the diaspora, as well as
all other human beings could face devastating
consequences
if
mad people
manage to get lured by money.
So I'd really like to find out more
about how A.Q. Khan went around
doing this. Musharraf has pardoned him;
well, that's
one end of the spectrum
but the other end of the spectrum is: we must make sure that
something like this can never
happen again.
CHANDA: Had A.Q. Khan
not engaged in these kind
of activities,
would it have been possible today for
Pakistan to sign a civilian nuclear agreement
with the United States as India has done?
BHUTTO: It's a difficult call,
it's a difficult call.
I think that India's a larger market,
and India is five times larger than Pakistan,
and certainly the post-Cold War, many academics
had predicted
that the Western world would
start coming closer to India,
so it's difficult to call, but certainly Pakistanis are
disappointed that we weren't
offered the same
civil nuclear
agreement.
I hope that at some stage we are able to
be offered such a civil nuclear cooperation,
but I also want to take my generation away
from the earlier generation's view
of tit-for-tat with India. I mean, we can't keep
competing with the Joneses.
We have to identify our own core
interests.
We need to pursue our core interests
and not seek to so overextend ourselves that we begin to
collapse from within, and I think that's what the policy of
strategic depth has done.
It's threatening
Pakistan from within,
and today, if I risk my life
to go back to my country,
I do it because I see the threat within
and I want to try and help my people
and help my country avert disaster.
CHANDA: The last question--if General
Musharraf
does not
doff his military uniform,
would you still go back to Pakistan before
the end of the year?
Yes, I will go back to Pakistan whether Musharraf
takes his uniform off or not.
I will go back to Pakistan this year
irrespective of whether we have an agreement
with General Musharraf or not,
but I hope that General Musharraf will review,
in light of the circumstances in Pakistan,
after the restoration of the Chief Justice of Pakistan,
his decision to seek reelection in uniform
from the present assemblies.
CHANDA: Thank you very much,
Mrs. Bhutto.
BHUTTO: Thank you. Thank you very much.